christian adeptes d'apple plus de 20 ans
a rendez vous avec le dernier écran 30
pouces de la marque
alors là
on frise la perfection
ou m'étais-je nous a écouté et on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir des choses aussi
un aussi joli c'est extraordinaire je
crois qu'on attend ça comme un comme un
enfant devant son arbre de noël quoi mac
ou pc
deux grands systèmes qui s'opposent
l'univers d'apple avec ses petites
icônes design et celui du pc plus
austère d'ailleurs pour les passionnés
de la pomme comme christian c'est
l'enfer ou le paradis
le blanc ou le noir la lumière c'est le
mcee et en plus tout ou dans le mac
femme révèle montre la lumière de toutes
façons blanc le côté propre net pour là
aussi voulait mener cette atmosphère
l'asim acculé voilà la force est avec
vous il existe même des théologiens de
la religion informatique
le pc serait protestants débrouillez
vous le mcs catholique je viendrai vous
voulez une machine sans mode d'emploi
parce que a priori les icônes et les
logiciels sont tellement simple à
comprendre et interpréter qui se passe
d'explication dans le monde pc j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est toi le ciel
t'aidera un homme et des mains peu dans
le cambouis l'univers pc serait donc
anarchique et les fans le reconnaissent
volontiers
les personnes qui ne sont pas dans
l'informatique et qui arrive devant ses
boutiques
c'est vraiment la jungle du pcc et il
existe des dizaines de marques qui
rivalisent sur les prix un bonheur quand
ils ont besoin de pc qui aiment bricoler
à moindre coût paul bac quand on la sait
presque on l'a on peut changer quelques
pièces un disque dur remettre de la
mémoire mais c'est très limité au niveau
changement je le paie serre on peut
vraiment tout changer
quand on veut c'est la libre concurrence
et le capital c'est plutôt capitalisme
et communisme
sa peau est apparentée pour certaines
personnel et germano effectivement il ya
des jeunes qui sont fous de pc et puis
c'est à celui qui aura la plus grosse
machine celle qui aura le plus vite ce
qui sera le plus décoré
on appelle cela le tuning lisa dettes ne
sont intéressés que par les entrailles
de l'ordinateur ici un circuit de
refroidissement aux faits sur mesure par
grégory pour éviter les surchauffes de
son microprocesseur ya pas de limites à
ce qu'on peut imaginer
on peut partir d'un boîtier on peut
partir de rien du tout de construire son
boîtier soit elle s'est vraiment on ne
peut avoir un acte créatif complet de a
à z tout en ayant une machine
fonctionnel
on peut même lycée dans l'ordinateur
vraie souris vivent c'est l'exemple
parfait de l'extrême qu'on peut avoir au
niveau du tennis construire une cage
pour une souris dans un ordinateur et
faire vivre la souris dans l'ordinateur
inconcevable pour un fan d'apple
d'ailleurs l'équipe de ce site internet
de jeux mac ne vois pas du tout
l'intérêt de retoucher l'humour d'un
ordinateur apple déjà un nous forcément
tous modifiés dans son ordinateur pour
que ça fonctionne quoi normalement on
achète un objet qui est dit et bien
pensé à la base de tout changer c'est
comme le jogging dans les bois cieux on
n'est quand même pas obligé de changer
le moteur de sa voiture pour travailler
sur fonctionne quoi mais c'est mc deux
états d'esprit différents à des zus
informatiques incompatibles